and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist today we're gonna disagree
yeah but in a good way yeah we're gonna
talk about disagreements we're gonna
talk about arguments we're gonna talk
about conflict and we're gonna answer
your questions with today's guest our
friend TK Coleman is in the studio today
what is happening welcome thanks for
being here man you can check out his
podcast it's called office hours it's
available wherever you listen to
podcasts thanks for joining us today not
the reason that I wanted to talk about
disagreements with TK Coleman by the way
I think this is your third time on the
podcast the first third time guest
congratulations it's kind of like a
three-peat Michael Jordan of the
minimalist you saying like the fourth
best of all time anyway yeah there we go
that's a disagreement but the thing I
like about disagreeing with t care how
does having conversations with TK is
we're able to disagree in a sort of
productive way and we were sitting down
for coffee the other day and you had
mentioned this book the metaphors we
live by and how quite often we the
reasons that we disagree is we're
disagreeing wrong we're sort of the
using language that instantly sets us up
for failure and for combat in a way can
you talk a little bit about that yeah so
that there's a really interesting book
by George Lakoff called metaphors we
live by and the premise of the book is
that the language that we use to
describe experience is not neutral that
our language actually shapes and
structures the experience so we not only
reveal how we think when we talk but we
also affect the way reality shows up for
us so one example of this is what he
calls the argument as war metaphor so if
you listen to the language that we use
when we talk about arguments it's all
battle based so things like she shot
down my arguments
he defended his position rigorously I
conceded her point I felt yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah and so a lot of our language
you know you know it's based on war and
then Lake Hoff invites us to consider
what new arguments feel like when you're
having one they feel like a struggle for
power right and and and that's related
to the way that we use the language and
so he invites us to consider alternative
metaphors what if we looked at arguments
as a kind of dance or as a kind of game
or as a kind of form of musical
composition how might we experience them
if we challenged ourselves to describe
them with a different linguistic
apparatus so to speak so now instead of
saying she's attacking my position she's
engaging my position right he's inviting
me to a conversation like you know you
don't mean like like like he's playing
around with this idea with me we're
collaborating on this discussion and and
and you begin to feel different emotions
around it and more importantly than just
the psychological experience it opens up
new vistas of possibility for where the
discussion can go and how we can learn I
think that's a very powerful idea yeah I
think this is awesome and because
disagreements I think that's kind of
what makes the world go around I mean we
all have different preferences we all
have different beliefs some of us have
you know different values but it's like
without that that that variety it would
be a very vanilla life it's like um it's
funny I was raised to believe that one
day God was gonna come down and just
turn the earth into this paradise and
everyone would have the same beliefs
everyone would have the same exact
thoughts they would all do the same
exact thing and you know ostensibly or
at first glance like that sounds really
awesome but when I really think about it
at its terminus it's like that's not
very what's where I'm looking for
there's no variety so it's it's just
it's not very exciting in a way yeah
yeah well we're inviting you to answer
some questions with us today about
disagree disagreements so our first
question is from Michelle in Washington
DC I have several friends at an
extremely large home in a very expensive
part of town we're talking about 6,000
square feet each I have many things in
common with
friends and I value our friendship and
time together the one thing I don't have
in common with these friends its desire
to live in a huge house as a child I
grew up in one but I now live in an
apartment with a bedroom that most would
consider extremely small I absolutely
love my tiny cozy space my question is
when my friends are showing me around
their home the size of their closets the
amount of bathrooms they have and how
their previous home could fit in their
master bathroom alone how do I respond
with the entire when the entire time I'm
thinking how ridiculous it all is the
staff they have to hire the amount they
paying utilities the long walks to get
from floor to floor is fine with them
but I feel if they're my response of Wow
and how lovely is conveying how great I
think it is the size of everything and
that I'm in that I'm also wanting a huge
home one day how do I respond during
these situations so these friends I'm
still developing a deeper friendship
with and I don't want to come off like
I'm making excuses for not having what
they have when I talk about minimalism
and my love for small homes and owning
possession this is a type of
disagreement even though it's a it's
like a subtle disagreement she doesn't
want to come off as disingenuous which I
can really appreciate that because you
don't want to say I really like those
bright yellow shoes you're wearing Ryan
if I actually don't like them I think
even those types of white lies are I
think they're dangerous and it becomes a
slippery slope what's interesting like
with friends we once what do we want
from our friends men we want to support
them we want to be supported so when we
find ourselves in these situations when
someone's you know talking really well
about something that you maybe don't
have a preference for it's like we want
to support our friend so we get caught
up in these little lies where we were
like oh yeah I like that too and that's
my favorite movie too right so so yeah I
add Michelle definitely doesn't want to
lie right she definitely doesn't want to
be disingenuous but also she is not
she's making a judgment she in fact she
uses language like ridiculous and that's
a type of judgment and that is not being
supportive when you're judging the
people that you care about most no Tk
what do you think about this you go to
someone's house and maybe you you you
are well less impressed and she in fact
used this word like I'm I'm not
impressed by their homes but
truth be told a giant house is
impressive by definition it's just a
different definition of the word like it
has impressed upon you some sort of
imagery and so you can say you know this
is really impressive and that's not for
you you don't have to say well but this
isn't for me when you get into
situations like this I think what you're
talking about with the language is so
important right now
so what would you talk to Michelle about
Michelle whenever I hear that word
Michelle like going to Obama moe well
what you want to do is uh I can only say
the word Michelle like Obama and then I
lose it for the rest of the senses so
likewise Michelle's better than my
impersonations they just like end up
sounding like weird vaguely Eastern yeah
almost from like Slovenia about her
judgement of these people's houses yeah
so if I'm hearing her correctly it
sounds like the tension is coming not
merely from a place of judgment but from
a place of wanting to show appreciation
and support for her friends right if it
was just a matter of judgment she could
be free to say I think this is
ridiculous and be on her way but these
are friends these are people that she
cares about it she wants to be
supportive and I think there are more
ways to support people than giving words
of affirmation or extending compliments
one of the best ways we can support
people is to simply be curious about
what inspires them to to inquire into
the reasons why they appreciate things
that are different from the things we
appreciate so if I'm at your place and
let's say you have a really big place or
a bunch of trinkets or whatever that
don't impress me trinkets I don't have
to force myself in order to be your
friends to say wow man this is really
cool here here's a better example for
you and I I go into your house and you
have a LeBron James poster right I'm
gonna think that's so ridiculous I'm
gonna judge you I'm gonna take that
ought to be a Michael Jordan poster
right so there's no way I'm gonna lie
and be like oh he's the greatest ever I
love that poster right I know judging
you John Stockton poster but okay right
but but what I could do to be supportive
as a friend is I can say hey man LeBron
James huh is that your guy is that is
that your man what like talk to me you
know like I can ask you about it and
then you can say well yeah so I'm from
Ohio he's from Ohio and you know I grew
up really admiring his game and Pappaw
blah blah and you can tell me all the
things about him that inspires you and
now I can easily affirm that i can
easily affirm the part of you that's
inspired by other people's greatness
right even if that's stimulated by
something different for me so don't
force yourself to give compliments to
things you don't appreciate instead
inquire into the reasons for why they
appreciate them and support them in that
way yeah appreciate the fact like I
appreciate the fact that Ryan likes to
skateboard or snowboard I can appreciate
that and I can inquire about I think
that's a great point
without needing the like well I need to
do that myself as well yeah yeah it's
it's like when so when you walk in you
see that LeBron James poster you have
one or two options you can either get
defensive and be like I can't believe
Josh likes LeBron James better than
whoever but but yes asking probing
questions that is the best way to get to
get someone to realize like oh my friend
does care about my interests my friend
does care about my personal preferences
asking them probing questions so
Michelle you don't want to lie to your
friends but you do want to find some
truths that you can tell them and some
of those truths are digging a little bit
deeper or you know you can if someone's
really excited about their house oh this
is my dream house like that's not an
attack on your tiny house that's just
saying hey your friend found a house
that is their dream house
so a very genuine thing you could say is
I'm really glad that you have your dream
house I'm really happy for you show me
more of your house so yeah don't don't
don't come up with these little lies
just try to look for the truths that you
could tell your friends or ask your
friends I think I think part of that is
success right she is defined success one
way for her it's a tiny house that
that's her version of success and I
think it's great she's framed in that
way she doesn't she's not taking someone
else's temple and saying their success
is how would I need to accomplish in
order for me to be successful so also
realizing that you both have sort of
different frames of success and their
version of success looks different from
yours and guess what
that adds that variety that Ryan was
talking about earlier because if they
are successful that doesn't make you any
less successful in fact
I think the opposite if you surround
yourself with people who are living
their version of their dream their their
success that enables you to be
successful in your own way as long as
you don't feel like they're they're
judging you as well and this is sound
like that's the problem here if you
shouldn't bring that up at all you just
have different preferences and that's
okay I just it's funny that sometimes
like I make this mistake when someone
like someone will say to me hey have you
seen the movie Inception like I want it
like my instinct is to be like yeah I
hated that movie and I want to go on and
on about how much I hated it but it's
like they're not asking for my opinion
they're trying to have a conversation
about a movie but if I allow myself to
have those knee-jerk reactions like I'm
shutting down this interaction with a
friend
I might being defensive myself put them
on the defense
so just avoiding just avoiding those
knee-jerk reactions like don't just
think that when someone you know shows
you their home or they talk about a
movie that they really care about your
opinion they just want to talk about a
movie or talk about their home one
common mistake I think we often make is
assuming that by listening to you and
fully hearing you out without protests
that I'm conceding your point and that's
not necessarily the case right I can
hear everything you have to say and go
interesting or what makes you think that
and the fact that I'm not protesting or
refuting you line by line doesn't mean
I'm agreeing with you
second thing Virginia City the acclaimed
Family Therapist has a very wonderful
book only about 40 pages call making
contact and it's all about cultivating
intimacy intimacy and relationships and
one of the things she says is that the
most powerful form of support is the
ability to make another human being feel
heard and seen and that's something that
you can convey without having to agree
with what it is they are listening to or
looking at right so when you say I love
this house to make you feel heard and
seen is to look past what it is you love
and to seek to understand the heart that
loves it I don't care about what you
love I care about the heart that loves
man - explain that - oh that's good
we'll put a link to all the books that
TK mentions throughout this podcast in
the show notes today I would I would
disagree with one thing I
use that word love you know Ryan and I
often try to distinguish enjoyment from
love and it's one thing I've been
teaching my daughter lately your Ella is
five and she's finally starting to get
it where she doesn't say I love this toy
anymore she says I I enjoy this toy and
I love mom and and tried to love people
and use things is the thing that we
often talk about now Michelle I want to
send you a copy of our book essential
what do I have it somewhere here it's an
essay collection with 150 different
essays and there's an entire chapter and
here about redefining what it means to
be successful so podcast Sean if you
could reach out to Michelle and send her
a copy of essential if you like our
podcast you'll like the audiobook
version or we will be happy to send you
the book book version or the eBook
version as well Ryan what time is it you
know what time is it it's time for our
lightning round where we answer
questions from social media we do we are
at the minimalists on Facebook Twitter
and Instagram TK Coleman is at TK
underscore Coleman on Twitter and you
can tweet him there and we usually
answer questions in this lightning round
TK you may remember less than 140
character responses to folks but not
really
we just ramble on a little bit until we
get something that's pithy we can tie it
up in a bow Sean puts all of our minimal
Maxim's in the show notes and you can
also find all of our minimal Maxim's in
one place now thanks to social Jessica
Lynn Williams she puts them all at
minimal Maxim's dot-com
Ryan do we have a question here to do
our first question is from Cathy what is
the best way to agree to disagree
particularly when one party insists on
being right what do you think what do
you think TK it's a tough one and this
is usually how arguments continue to get
blown out of proportion right escalated
and we if they can't agree to disagree
and it's like I have to be right I have
to be right now my pissed the answer to
this and we can expand on this is you
can all you can be always right or you
can get along choose one and the person
who even if you are always right and
you're rubbing that in your friends
faces that is a problem and I've I've
experienced this personally I've backed
off quite a bit in my 30s but I had to
always be right I had to win every
argument I had the wall
away with one last day that's not
particularly productive mmm yeah you
know it's interesting I think when we're
in these kinds of situations we
significantly underestimate the power
that we have to de-escalate these kinds
of situations so let's use the analogy
of fire if a fire is burning yeah I can
throw a wood in that fire and that's
gonna make it keep burning right or I
can just let it burn right and the fire
will eventually die of its own accord
when you're having an argument with
someone who insist on being right and
you insist on telling them that they're
not right what do you think is gonna be
the outcome of that right that's never
gonna end and you're never gonna achieve
that goal of agreeing to disagree on the
other hand what do you think happens
when someone insists on being right and
you listen to them and you ask a
question like hey why is that so
important to you like what is it that
makes you passionate about that belief
you know howdy how do you reconcile that
belief with the fact that so many people
disagree with you how do you how do you
deal with that like like how do you cope
with that like what are you doing in
your life to to implement that belief to
act on that to change the world in
accordance with your point of view it's
amazing what happens when you let down
the defenses and you just choose to be
interested in a person like the fight
stops right like it takes two to tango
when it comes to a fight it's like it's
like tug-of-war if you're pulling on the
end of the rope we can't have a good
game of tug-of-war
unless I'm pulling on the other hand if
I drop my in well the game's over right
it's the same way with an argument the
moment I drop my need to tell you that
you're wrong and I allow myself to be
curious about who you are how you're
applying those ideas what makes them
important to you you cease behaving like
someone that's fighting for power
because now you feel heard and now
you're having fun and you're relaxing
and you're telling me your point of view
yeah you know I think people just want
to be understood I mean that's really
what it comes down to so if you can show
someone that you understand where
they're coming from it's like I have you
know had different discussions arguments
disagreements whatever you call it and
it's I don't have to sit there and plant
my foot it's like just just a second ago
you were like Oh TK I don't like to I
don't like to use the word love because
you know love we love people use things
which I totally agree with but TK as my
friend like I'm not gonna judge you for
using that word love and I'm gonna
support you to use that you know in your
vernacular if that's what you choose to
do I'm not gonna like call you out on it
every single time so so just but but but
but I guess well here I'll give you my
pit the answer my pit the answer is this
short it's alright man but there was
some good stuff in there podcast on web
solutely tweeze it out my pit the answer
is this showing someone compassion is
the best form of support and again
that's all we want man we just want to
be supported and we want to support back
we want to be understood we want to show
people that we understand and showing
compassion that's kind of letting go of
that at the end of the rope and it's
also the opposite of judgment
absolutely when you said you just stop
back and listen that's not judging that
you might some judgments might
automatically pop up in your mind like
that's a crazy idea or whatever but
sometimes the judgment is just a mirror
that reflects our own insecurities to
the other person might be right
who was it was a neil degrasse tyson
talked about the three different types
of truth right there's the empirical
truth sort of fact-based truth is right
then there's subjective truth was true
for me like I really like the color blue
and Ryan likes the color green or
whatever or and then there's political
truth which just is if you say something
enough times it becomes true even if
it's not that's so crazy like so many
forms of truth right and and really what
we're talking about here is many of
these judgments it's a subjective truth
and we think of these things as as as if
they're empirical and and and they're
immutable and they're just solidified
they're foundational truths now most of
them are just my own little judgments my
own little insecurities my that's how my
brain is working that's all of our
brains work man like we just we want to
project it's again it's like with the
movie Inception it's like it frustrates
me because it was such a good move it
doesn't frustrate me but like I think
about it I'm like wow is that movie like
why is everyone all about that movie but
it's like that is my subjective or my
yeah that is my subjective truth it's my
preference like that is that's that's
that's nothing that I should force on
anyone else and if someone loves that
movie then I should be like I'm really
glad that you found enjoyment in that
movie cuz I wish I did
those people who like would you put the
in terment I'm not already gave it oh
yeah you can all you can be always right
or you can get along
choose one what's next question right
our next one is from Teddy which is the
most effective media to add value to
people's lives is it a blog or YouTube
yes so I I like this question when it
was an opening into question and then
Teddy finishes it with more specificity
with like as if you have this binary
choice right
well TK has a blog and Matthew Vella has
a YouTube channel which one is is best
rarely what's better CNN or Fox News
right well no actually I like the Dayton
Daily News in it so it really depends on
who well here's my pithy answer for you
by an airy thinking leads to greyscale
rainbows yeah and and so you know what I
think it really depends on what is
appropriate for you we talk to Matthew
Vella about this a little bit he is
you're really popular on YouTube now
he's the guy who directed our are you
you know Matt you you did his podcast he
directed our documentary we worked on it
together and he's he's making like a
little miniature documentary every week
on YouTube and that is the best platform
for him it's the most appropriate one
for him from us blogging is where we
started and it's it's still the thing
that that we that we use to convey most
of our message now but there's another
option here we're podcasting right now
or what about making a documentary or
writing a book what is the appropriate
medium and think I realized you've been
you've been blogging a lot lately folks
want to check that out TK Coleman calm
so so for you that has been a way for
you to express yourself but the it
doesn't mean it's the only medium
through which we need to communicate
what are your thoughts yeah so I grew up
in the church right and I remember this
one time someone asked the pastor they
said hey so there's so many translations
of the Bible there's the King James
there's the NIV there's the NRV what's
the best translation to get and the
pastor set the one that you'll actually
read right so my answer to the question
hey what's the best medium to use to get
my message out there I
say the one that actually brings you the
most joy because we could we can study
statistics and we can study human
behavior and we can say hey everyone
seems to be hanging out on Instagram but
if you're miserable on Instagram or
you're not enjoying that because writing
makes you come more alive then maybe you
need to go where your energy is flowing
don't start with where you think the
audience is don't start with where you
think people will respond start with
what makes you come alive start with
what fires you up and keeps you
motivated favorite quote is by oh shoot
Howard Thurman he says ask not yourself
what the world needs but rather what
makes you come alive for that is what
the world needs people who have come
alive same applies to the social media
tools you use fascinating about this is
we often feel compelled because in fact
Matt saw this at first when he first
started creating things on his own he's
like well I'm gonna start a blog because
that's what other people do and I think
it's great if that's what you want to do
is right right but he didn't want to
write he didn't like writing and by the
way he's one of the most genius
filmmakers I've ever seen why start a
blog when you have this talent in a
skill set I say yeah we differentiate
talent from skill talent he was born
with some sort of eye for something but
his skill he's developed over the last
decade and you go back and look at some
of the silly folk videos he made a
decade ago it's completely different
from what he's doing right now he's
developed the skills over time the same
is true for anyone if you haven't
developed the skill yet you might have
some sort of in born talent too right
but you're gonna be a terrible writer at
first and that's okay you could still
put it out there in the world if you're
trying to add value to someone's life
ultimately what you're gonna want to do
is help people solve their problems and
the question for you is which mediums
should you use to help people solve
their problems yeah it's kind of this
question I kind of look at it's like
what's better audio book or the book
book and like for me it's audio if you
ask Colin right he could read faster
than someone could read it to him it's
it's yeah that's it's not it's not
binary like that my short answer would
be this seek different opinions and
points of view to make a decision for
yourself and that's really I think
that's key especially in today's world I
mean at the end of every podcast what do
I say read more get informed it's
because we have to make decisions for
ourselves we're
one media outlet or one form of media to
give us all of our information I mean
we're kind of doing ourselves an
injustice absolutely all right you know
it looks like we have several more
surprise questions this week TK this is
going to give fun we got some questions
about accidentally offending people we
talked a little about this a little bit
at lunch the other day and I said hey
save that for the podcast you were just
dropping like a lot of Dimes at large
[Laughter]
another question here about balancing
well-being with building a new business
a question about product a question
about productive disagreements
communication and listening also this is
this is where it gets juicy TK religion
politics sex race relations abortion
pineapple on pizza and what's the
correct way to put a roll of toilet
paper on the dispenser oh that last one
is easy I have some thoughts on this and
I'll let me tell you this right now it's
not the way that Rebecca does it all
I'll say is if you google patent for
toilet paper roll it's right there and
like the original patent for the toilet
paper roll there is it there is a
correct way that's patented on how it
should work I assure you no matter how
what it says there it's not the way the
Rebecca does it I can promise you we're
going to talk about that if you want to
hear all of that you can listen to this
week's maximal episode available
exclusively on patreon that's right
you're currently listening to our weekly
minimal episode but each week Ryan and I
record an entirely different long-form a
maximal episode on the minimalists
private podcast which gives us the
private space we need to talk about
topics we don't usually discuss in
public boy did we talk about some topics
this week that we don't talk about in
public good times
oh my goodness yeah yeah I can't believe
you took your shirt off during that well
I was so angry come at me
the yeah it turned to fisticuffs and
that's why I was bleeding there I was
literally bleeding during that but that
was unrelated actually all right Plus
patreon is the best way for us to fund
this podcast to keep it 100%
advertisement free when you subscribe to
the minimalist private podcast on
patreon you'll also receive a personal
link so that our maximal episodes play
in your favorite podcast app you also
get access to our entire back catalogue
of more than a hundred private podcast
episodes find all the details and all
the good stuff including an additional
private podcast episode every week over
at the minimalists comm slash support
ryan what else you got for us this week
being informed is more important than
ever these days so I want to encourage
people to read more and get informed and
now here are some voicemail comments and
tips from our listeners hello I'm Tina
I'm from Baltimore I often hear the
question about how to get your spouse in
law so I wanted to share my 3 my
boyfriend and I have been living
together since November of 2006 and I
found minimalism and 2018
after that time I made the effort to
really go through my belongings and
figure out what was actually valuable
while bagging up items for Goodwill he
told me how proud he was of me for
decluttering and finally getting rid of
my storage unit I thanked him and told
him how I only wish I made the time to
do it sooner then I told him that he
wanted to go through his items I could
wait to go to Goodwill tomorrow you know
this was my moment to finally talk to
him about minimalism and asking him to
get rid of his stuff and he looked at me
blankly and said what stuff would I get
rid of I don't really have any stuff
choking back my frustration I asked him
what did he mean and he responded to me
right when you moved in I gave up a lot
of stuff to make room for you I let go
some things I thought were really
important even some of my father's
belongings your place was a lot bigger
and cheaper and gave that up to make me
feel more comfortable and
for my happiness so mr. think that has
now either have a lot of value or you
gave me as a gift and I looked around I
noticed most of the stuff in our place
was my ounce and if I ever moved out it
would be really empty so my point being
is to look around your place is it
really his stuff in the way or is it
your clutter is that your decorations
and your mementos making you feel
claustrophobic with you with the place
you share ever be empty if you left my
other idea is faster spells the dust my
boyfriend always gets sidetracked and
starts going through his stuff well
trying to just everything so even though
he doesn't have much to get rid of at
least he still actively goes through and
queens of zone belonging hi Josh and
Ryan this is Michelle from West
Lafayette Indiana I just wanted to leave
a comment regarding the digital clutter
episode episode 173 which was awesome by
the way there was a question about
feeling kilts when taking people off
social media unfriending unfollowing or
what have you
once in a blue moon I take a radical
approach and delete my profile
altogether now I realize this won't be
everyone's favorite idea however I've
realized over time that the people who
matter most to meit will friend me again
or vice versa it's also nice to take
what I consider a deep breath or maybe
even a detox from that particular social
media site again I realize that this is
not everyone's cup of tea but it might
be worth considering alright Joe thanks
again the TK Coleman for joining us
today make sure you check out his
podcast office hours find all of his
wonderful writings over at TK Coleman
calm and real quick four right here
right now here's one thing that's going
on in the life of the minimalist Ryan
and I often give talks at different
universities organizations corporations
and conferences such as Harvard Apple
Google all state si P and many other
organizations next we'll be in Miami in
June
hanging out giving a talk about less
sometimes we talk about simple work we
talk about living simply we talk about
what it means to live a meaningful life
with last week we usually take on about
one speaking gig per quarter so we can
give it the time that it deserves also I
hate travelling so we never take on more
than one a month and so if you're
interested in hiring the minimalists to
speak at your organisation or event you
can head on over to the minimalists comm
slash speaking if you have a question
comment or minimalism tip for our
podcast leave us voicemail four zero six
two one nine seven eight three nine or
send a voice memo to podcast at the
minimalists comm you can comment on this
episode at youtube.com slash the
minimalists and if you want our show
notes in your inbox sign up for our
e-mail list at the minimalists comm
you'll also receive our simple Sunday
emails each week and for our added value
this week let's listen to John Mayer's
new single you heard this one Ryan I
haven't my hate singles put out an album
it's called I guess I just feel like
because I think we've all sort of felt
this way at some point it's it's almost
like being fed up with disagreements and
to me it was an honest reflection on
what disagreements sometimes do to our
lives sometimes the disagreements in our
lives they get the best of us and they
put us in this this this feeling and I
think this song captures that and if you
all leave here today with that musical
choice if you leave here today with just
one message we hope it's this love
people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time
minimus